foreign
[Music]
this week things got messy in Hollywood
Disney announced massive postponements
to the MCU and Avatar movies Deadpool 3
has to deal with one less popular
character and the new Star Wars movie
finally get their theatrical release
dates plus Robin Williams makes a
surprise return as Genie the Sonic
series Knuckles gets prominent new cast
additions and there's a first look at
the new spider-verse film The Spider
within are you excited here's the Kino
check news
while fans of Sonic the Hedgehog are
eagerly awaiting the third part after
Sonic 2. another project continues to
take shape some new additions to the
cast have now been announced before the
spin-off series Knuckles including a
star from Back to the Future up to now
we already knew that the film voice of
Knuckles Idris Elba is also part of the
series other members of the movie cast
are also returning including Adam Pally
as Wade Whipple and Tika Sumpter as
Maddie new to the cast is Carrie elways
known for movies such as saw The
Princess Bride and Robin Hood Men in
Tights another prominent newcomer is
Christopher Lloyd Shirley better known
to many as Dr Emmett Brown from the back
to the future movies likewise joining
the cast are actress stalker Channing
comedian Paul shear and Rob hubel
details on the actor's roles however are
not yet known the live action series
follows Knuckles on an entertaining
Adventure as he trains Wade as his
Protege and teaches him the ways of a
fighter it is set between the second
film and Sonic 3 and can thus be seen as
a kind of preparation for the new
feature film it is therefore fitting
that the team from the movies is also in
charge of implementing the series a
release date for Knuckles is currently
unknown but the series will be available
for streaming on Paramount plus
naturally before the theatrical release
of Sonic the Hedgehog 3 on December 20th
2024.
Spider-Man across the spider-verse gets
some support at The anisee Animation
Festival in France the short film The
Spider within has now been presented and
it's apparently way creepier than the
main movie series the Sony film is about
Miles Morales who suffers from anxiety
because of his life as Spider-Man and
goes on a Trippy ride through his
subconscious a first image already shows
that the short film remains faithful to
the look of the original director
Jarrell dampier is part of Sony's talent
development program lens based on his
own experience with sleep paralysis he
wanted to tell a Spider-Man story that
unlike other stories focuses more on
horror with this genre he said it would
be possible to appeal very well to a
young audience because they would
sympathize strongly with their beloved
character in addition it is very
relatable that Miles has to struggle
with such problems due to his
experiences even if something like that
normally has no place in big blockbuster
movies the director himself was
surprised that the unusual idea met with
a lot of approval especially with
spider-verse producers and writers Phil
Lord and Chris Miller who were
immediately thrilled to further explore
miles's abysses how the spider within is
to be classified chronologically in
relation to the feature films is
something dampier is still keeping Under
Wraps there might be some Easter eggs to
discover though it's not yet clear where
exactly the movie will be released
however we can well imagine a double
feature with beyond the spiderverse
which opens in cinemas on March 29 2024
it could also be possible that the
spider within will be included as a
bonus in the home Cinema release of
across the spider-verse we will keep you
up to date either way
after Avatar in 2009 it took 13 years to
make Avatar 2 the way of water
originally Avatar 3 and the other
sequels were supposed to be released a
little quicker but that won't happen
anymore since the whole movie series has
been massively postponed up to 2031. the
extensive release postponements at
Disney do not spare James Cameron's
Blockbuster series either after Avatar 3
was scheduled for December 19 2024 until
recently the film will now be released a
year later on December 19
2025. the other movies will be hit even
harder as Parts 4 and 5 will be delayed
by three years Avatar 4 is now slated
for December 21st 2029 and Avatar 5 for
December 19 2031 22 years after the
first Avatar film as a small consolation
producer John Landau released a first
behind the scenes photo of avatar 3. on
it we can see a monitor on set showing
how the actors are already being
replaced live on location with a rough
version of the navi it is definitely a
good tool for the creative minds behind
the camera should there not be further
postponements like with Avatar 2 the way
of water we'll see at the end of 2025
whether the effort was worth it we'll
keep our fingers crossed
lately we got the impression that just
about every former Deadpool actor would
also be in Deadpool 3 plus of course
newcomer Hugh Jackman as Wolverine but
now it's clear at least one popular
character won't be back German American
actress zazie beats has now confirmed in
an interview with decider that she will
not return as domino in Deadpool 3. this
might come as a surprise to many as she
was an integral part of Deadpool 2. in
fact she doesn't have any info about the
third film but is definitely looking
forward to the outcome the project has
been the subject of some discussion
lately due to the writer strike not a
single line of the script may be changed
on set a big problem for Ryan Reynolds
and the team who usually improvise a lot
in order to find the best gags there is
also good news however unlike many
Disney Productions that have currently
been massively pushed back Deadpool 3 is
now scheduled to be released several
months earlier instead of November 2024
the new US release is now set for May
2024.
amidst all the hubbub about the numerous
postponements at Disney there are also
releases for which it has now been
announced for the first time ever when
they are expected to see the light of
day in addition to friends of family
entertainment suitable for children
science fiction fans in particular will
get their money's worth Star Wars fans
can Mark some dates in red on their
calendars three new movies will be
released on May 22nd 2026 December 18
2026 and December 17 2027 though it has
not been revealed yet which of the
upcoming projects belongs to which date
rumor has it that the May 2026 film is
the new story centered around Rey
directed by charmeen obey genoi the
Mandalorian Creator Dave filoni is also
rumored to be working on a Star Wars
film as is Indiana Jones 5 director
James Mangold the new alien movie with
the working title alien Romulus from
Evil Dead director Fede Alvarez has now
also been given a theatrical release
date The Standalone movie which is
intended to work independently of the
other films in the franchise will be
released on August 16
2024. those who like things a little
friendlier can look forward to the live
action remake of Moana the movie with
Dwayne Johnson and one of the main roles
is now planned for June 27 2025.
due to the wga strike there are massive
changes in the release dates of the MCU
Disney has now presented all the new
dates and Marvel fans will have to
adjust to some of the waiting times for
many projects whether they like it or
not here's what the new release schedule
looks like the recently renamed Captain
America 4 Brave New World is delayed by
a couple of months and will now hit
theaters on July 26 2024. The Ensemble
movie Thunderbolts is pushed to December
20th 2024 and blade is even postponed to
February 14
2025. Fantastic Four is now slated for
May 2nd 2025 while the two Avengers
films Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars moves
to May 1st 2026 and May 7 2027
respectively the problems at Marvel are
not abating actually the MCU ought to
pick a pace again after some recent
sagging and have a new big goal in mind
with Jonathan Majors as Kang however the
actor is in the midst of abuse
proceedings the focus on his character
May therefore prove to be a mistake the
numerous postponements now add to this
and raise the big question of whether
the MCU can be put back on track for
Success James Gunn's DCU is after all
just waiting to assert the Throne of
superhero blockbusters
Disney revealed its film Once Upon a
studio at The Animation Festival in
anesee more than 400 classic Disney
characters are expected to make an
appearance including the genie from
Aladdin once again voiced by the late
Robin Williams the short film lasts nine
minutes and has been described by
viewers as a sort of Night at the Museum
with Disney characters according to
director Dan Abraham the movie is
supposed to be a love letter to the long
history of Disney Studios and its
viewers and was made to celebrate the
100th anniversary of the film company it
combines hand-drawn animation with CGI
and real characters in addition to Peter
Pan Moana Olaf from Frozen or Flash from
zootopia many viewers will be
particularly touched by the appearance
of Genie the famous speaking part of
Robin Williams was realized by using old
recordings of them which were put
together to new dialogues it is
speculated that once upon a studio will
play in theaters attached to Disney's
new film wish which opens in theaters on
November 22nd 2023
that was all for this week's news but
there's more we've got some awesome new
trailers on our Channel such as one for
Pixar's Elio and one for Paw Patrol 2
The Mighty movie make sure to check them
out thanks for watching and see you next
week for more kenocheck news
[Music]
thank you